you know being a customer Centric
company that is led by the market
basically what we've done is we've taken
our insights and we transform them into
smart prompt so we basically engineer
prompts and then we use those prompts in
variety of different gen models both
llms contextual models and diffusion
models meaning visual models so we
cannot just come up with the data points
the insights the recipes the
recommendations we can come up with
actual meaningful valuable marketing
materials marketing
[Laughter]
[Music]
outputs Asaf yanai welcome to 20min
leaders really excited to be sharing
another episode with you here on on my
show I'm I'm particularly excited about
you know the the space that you're in
the journey that you're in so so really
thank you for for being here and thank
you for taking the time sure thank you
for having me and uh I'm excited uh uh
about the opportunity as well amazing so
so before we dive into Alice and Ai and
what are you doing with video analytics
and helping organizations with really
understanding what what really makes for
great engagement and and uh and great
user experience in terms of human to
digital media interaction tell me a
little bit about yourself and your
connection to the space yeah um so first
I'm uh I'm I'm almost 37 36 years old uh
married one kid um my professional life
was always around online marketing um in
the past 15 years that's what I've been
doing um and actually Allison is the
third company I'm I'm co-founding around
that around that space um so the the
online marketing uh area is no stranger
uh to me uh nor you know
entrepreneurship around uh online
marketing um but actually you know we're
going to speak about Allison today um
actually the the concept of Allison the
the the idea behind it uh came to me uh
through my
experiences you know working in again in
the past 15 years with some of the
biggest brands uh in the world from
Proctor and Gamble unil to you know big
traditional Banks like Bank of America
and HSBC through online first companies
from Tinder and okay Cupid and ways and
hellofresh and others um and my
experience as working with them actually
kind of sparked the the idea and sparked
the uh the concept of
Allison okay so so what is the really
the the the core problem that that you
identified with organizations like you
un lever and others what was the
obviously the the context of user
engagement and engaging with customers
in in meaningful ways that's that's top
of mind and and and I guess is is a big
driver for for creating results in terms
of product engagement what is the big
gap that you've identified working with
them yeah good question
um so look um from what we're seeing it
what actually happens uh today online is
that um every single brand every single
company every single Enterprise that
wants to scale sell their service
product Etc to their um users Target
audiences um they have to use online
marketing right that's uh that's one of
the main uh the main focus areas for
marketing today um you know Facebook
Google Tik Tok Snapchat and and other
types of platforms these are the main
drivers for uh sales revenues and even
brand awareness and brand positioning uh
these days now what we're seeing today
is that
90% okay of the creatives that we see
online are actually videos so there is a
clear focus on videos from platform side
right Google YouTube uh meta Instagram
Tik Tok Etc they they're all
prioritizing video content over other
types of content to us as Brands as as
advertisers or Enterprises we prefer
those platforms and we pref fa video to
to engage with our audiences because we
can deliver multiple messages because
it's interactive because we can hyper
personalize the videos and the contents
and also us as users you know the other
side of those platforms the other side
of the advertising is meeting the users
and also us as users we prefer video
content to engage with so here comes the
value or Here Comes The Challenge right
how do we as brands or as advertisers
how do we know what's the right video
composition or what's the right video
content that we should be engaging with
our
audiences so the simple answer is that H
we don't really know we think we know
but we don't really know typically we
have a concept in mind a theory or
hypothesis and we want to put it to test
we want to see if it's if it's actually
performing so every every single company
on Earth are basically bound to use a
wasteful inefficient even ancient
process that's called AB test right
that's the best way of testing creativ
video content um ads
today but again AB tests are a thing of
the past um and let me tell you maybe a
a a very quick short story about uh
about yeah about
that so uh I I come from a family of
entrepreneurs myself but my father he
studied Marketing in the80s now he's a
marketing expert marketing veteran and
when he studied everything and when he
practiced online Market sorry marketing
everything was
offline so a few years ago I had an un
unconventional unorthodox chat with my
dad not about what I'm having kids and
you know what's up with a family but
more about work so I kind of questioned
them like that back then in the 80s when
you had marketing campaigns how did you
validate how did you test how did you
you know brought your concept or
hypothesis to life when it comes to the
marketing activities so he looked at me
in a very funny way and he said Asaf
it's easy we AB test
and this was in the 880s right so what
we're learning from this is that you
know 40 50 even 60 years later
everything is digital everything is
online ones and zeros but we are still
using you know wasteful inefficient
manual processes like AB test and this
is exactly the first concept or the
first mission that we set to our that
Allison to completely revolutionize and
replace this entire process with data
and AI how do you do that in
video because there's one thing to AB
test then in websites you can create
cool heat maps and see where the user
goes and the the mouse clicks how do you
do that in a world where there's a piece
of content sometimes it's long sometimes
it's very very short it's expensive to
create maybe you'll share that it's
getting less expensive but that's a
teaser but how how does that work so
you're absolutely right it takes a lot
of time to create a Content it costs a
lot of money you need skills and
expertise um and also um AB test and and
this is my humble personal Theory anyway
but I think that in the past few years
the reason we saw marketing teams grow
so much and eventually consist the
biggest department the biggest teams the
biggest exp expense
within uh an Enterprise is because of
those operations that are extremely
heavy in terms of headcount time
resources that you needed to put into
place to create a successful well just
an AB test operations so again at Alison
what we do is completely different
instead of testing multiple creatives we
basically plug in to your existing ad
account and we scan every single piece
of creative that you ever tested ever
experimented with ever launched or ever
tried then using 10 different AI engines
we run a process called feature
extraction we're basically identifying
thousands of thousands of features from
those videos like sound voice over
background colors buttons logos emotions
facial expressions card face
Etc and then we're basically correlating
those features with the actual
performance so once correlated basically
this mechanism completely replaces the
ab test but it generates a lot more
efficiency because we can tell our
customers exactly but exactly what's
driving their performance within
specific campaign domains areas products
use cases Concepts Etc so they don't
have to test they have to create a
version then we already know that it's
going to succeed and then the platform
basically feeds itself with a ongoing
feedback loop so even our
initial um outputs that are already
optimized are then being able to uh
optimize again and again and again in a
in a in a in a feedback loop so that's
how we get it on videoos hey can you
show an example of what an actionable
Insight could look like for an an large
organization as a result of of of
Allison ai's product what would be a I
guess if you're are you working with the
with directly with the creative
directors or is it with the advertiser
campaigns who who is sort of the Persona
that makes most use of the insights that
you're Gathering so it's a good another
good question that also leads me to
another Gap that we see today in the
industry so another Gap is that
typically the media team the marketing
team are completely detached from the
design or the studio teams so basically
there's a disconnect between our
research or optimization or media uh
operations and the creative on so I'm
get I'm guessing you already know my
answer but Allison another you know
extreme value that we bring to the table
is that um both U marketing or media
teams and the creative or design teams
are both the personas and both the users
within the same platform so first they
can communicate between each other
between the two different teams but it
also Bridging the Gap the language
barrier gap between
media um language and media metric and
design or visual uh components and
elements absolutely so walk me through a
little bit what you're saying in the
space I think one of the interesting
drivers that that are happening is that
there's the notion of AB testing is only
as useful as the Velocity in which you
can experiment and and get the insights
but then actually put them into practice
so if you're creating one creative per
month then the the the the velocity
which you can improve is is is low but
in a world in which generative AI
potentially helps you generate a lot of
creatives and you can actually guide the
generation based on the insights that
you that you have then then you can
actually really really re reap the
benefits of of AB testing is this
already happening I mean are we where
are we at in terms of the technological
progression and Adoption of of of
creation tools do you think that empower
the inside to reap the benefits from the
insights that you're generating so yeah
I think it's already happening we're at
Allison we the Forefront of this uh
Revolution or the Forefront of this uh
change uh basically what we're seeing is
that um most of the companies they're
still using those uh
manual um heavy you know operations like
AB test although for example in Allison
we already you know bring uh new tools
new capabilities that are far more um uh
efficient uh quicker uh takes less uh
cost and
expenditures um and you know it's
already live but let me maybe give you
another uh example uh of one of our
customers so I think it will help you
understand how this really benefits our
customers
so um you know we're working with with
some of the biggest names you know in
the industry Fortune 500 companies from
LG Electronics to BOS to Warner Brothers
and Ferrera Kendy company for example
now imagine that they run AB tests all
the time
now let's say they have five creatives
in an AB test and eventually one is the
winning creative right so typically they
throw away all the four other versions
that they've tried and this becomes
complete waste but then comes again the
question I started with okay this is the
winning version of the ab test how do we
know if it's the optimal
version so we still don't though so
again there is a continuous AB test
going on there now one of output that
Allison is this inside this
recommendation we we talked about and
imagine that the level of granularity is
infinite okay so for example with LG we
can help them understand that they need
to create 15 seconds videos for Facebook
and those 15c videos should have four
scenes in total and we can tell them
exact L what is the composition what is
the story The Script but also the
elements the visual features that should
appear in this type of video so think of
it as a as a recipe right as a recipe
for a winning video
or a successful video based on your own
business goals kpis audiences users Etc
but there's another thing here because
we've also realized that in every online
marketing campaign that is successful
there is a part that is done manually
and takes a lot of our um uh attention
and this part is called competitive
research or competitive intelligence
looking at our direct competitors
creatives and understanding from this
what they're leveraging if it's working
for them and if we as as the brand if we
tried those things before and what was
the outcome this this entire process is
man is is done manually today
and it's it's broken because you have to
Mally go to different platform different
areas and with your bare eyes try to
understand what's going on it's almost
impossible so I'm very proud to say it
and more so in this in this podcast but
Allison with the only company in the
world that runs this entire process not
just automatic or but at scale so we
scan every single one of your
competitors creatives and we'll show you
what are the gaps between you and your
competitors and then we'll uh push it uh
uh uh to the recommendation as a form of
an insight as a form of this uh
ingredient in this recipe and when we've
asked our customers if they're using the
insights if it's helpful if they're you
know they're being enriched by it they
said look this is phenomenal there's no
way on Earth that our teams could even
you know digest or or come up with this
level of granularity and those level of
insights but these are insights these
are data points this is not a tool and
we need a tool that I've seen to our
existing workflow so we can manage the
entire process and not just fragments of
this process by different uh tools so
you know being a a a a customer Centric
uh company that is led by uh by by the
market basically what we've done is
we've taken our insights and we
transform them into smart prompts so we
basically engineer prompts and then we
uh uh use those prompts in variety of
different gen models both llms cont
textual models and diffusion models
meaning visual models so we cannot just
come up with the data points the
insights the recipes the recommendations
we can come up with actual meaningful
valuable marketing material marketing
outputs for example a brief right how
long does it take us to write a brief
and do we have data actual data points
to back up our briefs typically not
really so at Allison it's not just that
it takes a second to generate a swad
brief but it's based on billions of data
points correlated with the business
goals and kpi are trying to achieve
think of it as a brief from the
future and then after the brief there's
another process that is typically being
done manually and it's called
storyboarding or storyboard taking the
brief and bring it to life right
visualize how the video is going to look
like this is typically done by the
creative teams and again based on their
subjective experiences based on
brainstorming Etc and Allison we
completely automate this entire process
uh as well based on the briefs and based
on the prompts we also generate
automatically on demand storyboards that
are far more visualized far more
exciting and far more relevant for uh
your audience say as a customer and
lastly you know the Holy Grail of of of
advertising the holy gril of uh closing
the loop between the research the
analysis and then the production we are
now also producing generating a video
not just a video not just the raw
footage
but actual commercials and actual ads
that are also editable and be able to
modify the um the output the videos not
not by creating or designing but by
playing around with data points and
insights awesome so so effectively
taking the taking you know the the core
generative AI use cases combining them
with the analytics that you're already
that you're already creating using the
predictive AI model and then combining
them to create better engaging creatives
um so very excited to see where the
space is headed very excited to see
where where Alis and AI is headed thank
you again Asaf for for taking the time
to meet with me and for sharing your
product and your and and your vision and
the journey really appreciate it very
timely um it's all happening now so uh
run fast and I'm excited to see you in
action thank you very much thank you
Michael thank you for having me thank
you thank you